hello and welcome to the demo of the
material science online masters course
before I go into the actual course demo
I would like to provide a brief
background information first these are
fully online course offering off the
current on-campus course which armasight
204 MSI 256 audiences our incoming matza
master students and professional
learners and it was launched for Summer
2018 quarter in both courses we
integrated the campus and su class
platform to benefit from several
features first canvas the student facing
platform automatically pulls in the
student registration data information
from axis also it has a pen and paper
problem set and exam assignments
available so when you want to have a pen
and paper kind of exams or assignments
it is easy to unload the scanned version
of the assignment second is a su class
which has a great knowledge check
questions it has a robust part of having
multiple choice questions true and false
or a drag-and-drop or a peer instruction
also it has a good player for the
lecture videos so this is why we use two
platforms the course format it has the
introduction video also lecture slide
and videos as I mentioned short
knowledge check quizzes to check for
understanding some of the occasional
supplementary videos such as screen site
chat with using the tablet to explain
the charts or graphs also as I mentioned
for canvas part problem sets which is
completed on pen and paper and unloaded
to the platform also midterm and final
exam use the pen and paper so let me
show you the course demo now so the
course it has the syllabus and it talks
about topic the class format and some of
the great disparate
distribution and then a course schedule
was there the due dates this is same for
solar cells as well course contents are
in modules and this models are actually
pulled in from su class units and
formats I to five six course it was
conditional setting meaning students
will need to complete all knowledge
check questions to see the next unit the
course material has insure video which I
am going to show you right now and as
you can see the su class video player
has a good way of showing the transcript
on the right hand side and students can
actually click on the transcript just
jump into that part so it start with the
introduction with the instructors face
showing up welcome back to the world
headquarters of solar cells fuel cells
in bed after the students see the
introduction video they usually go to
the PowerPoint video which is like this
and then when I mix them I form a
solution a be also for met site two five
six course we also have like a screen
site chat which means after they do the
problem solving session the instructor
provided some explanation for that
problem reaction we're gonna run it
through a load resistor and then it
could appear so the eye light is gonna
go in this direction or the J so now
let's go on to the knowledge of
questions so formats I 204 they had a
lot of submit and compare and some of
the multiple-choice questions
and what the way that thing you do is is
askings of the statement and asking
whether this is true and false and
rather than just having true and false
we ask the students to kind of think
about it and reflect on why they thought
it was false so let me say it was false
and then maybe talk about why and then
if they click on someone and compare
they can see professors response so this
way they can reflect back on what they
answered and then kind of compare their
answer with the professor's answer also
there was a peer instruction question as
well since this is the question inside
the actual course I will show one from
the demo course and the open EDX so the
way they do it is you have the initial
answer to choose and they explain to
other students why you thought this is
the real answer and I'm just going to
write down the example answer next step
you can see other students answer and
then you have an opportunity to choose
the final answer so this is the way that
you can choose the students to kind of
reflect on the questions rather than
just having the students choose ABC and
then then that's it so that was one of
the things that were incorporated into
the mid/side course other things are
drag-and-drop questions which is not
available in canvas and this was one of
the reason that why we want to have this
kind of interactive quiz questions
inside this kind of drag-and-drop is
pretty much helpful for students to
think about it and we'll try to have the
right answer and you can also use this
for graphs or anything like that to
other parts we know we mentioned that is
even though the open attacks was really
really good with still knowledge sir
questions the instructor wanted to keep
the pen and paper style for the exams
and problem solving so that part canvas
is pretty good with it so we use canvas
feature for this part they can download
the homework problems and then complete
it skin it or take a picture of it and
then unload it this is same for the
midterm exam they have two hours to
finish this so that's a little bit
different from the homework and once
they are done with it
so students can unload their skin
version to the canvas and the TAS can
actually give them a feedback or
feedback using this kind of speed grader
as well so this is why we want to use
the canvas feature and pen and paper
worked pretty well for this part and
then the last one is discussion board so
format sorry two five six we had the
discussion board and it was more like a
poster questions an answer to a question
original feedback and this is more like
a participation point so it wasn't like
a big grade that is involved but we
would like to have at least the students
engagement or involvement and it looks
like the students kind of asked
questions and then they answered it and
it was pretty much helpful for the
students so that was actually it for the
course demo thank you for watching and
if you have any questions about the demo
you can contact me my name is Chi choy
you can contact me via email teacher at
stanford.edu or if you have any
questions or want a consultation you can
go to ppto that's time for that edu and
Rick it's the consultation related to
this demo or anything like you want to
have for online course development thank
you